i've been talking to you guys for a
while about how if you start tearing
down
monuments and statues that it's never
going to stop as a matter of fact i have
no doubt
as i often say that eventually the
progressives of 2030 will tear down the
obama library which is being built in
chicago right now because let's not
forget that barack obama not only
did he obviously play
uh ftse with white supremacists by
becoming president of the united states
at a time that we were deeply racist and
all that stuff and he didn't solve
racism because then why would we need
old joe biden but he was against gay
marriage first time around so obviously
barack obama was an anti-lgbt bigot
hated gay people did not think that they
were equal
to other people right like this is just
the line of thinking that these people
will do and they will justly burn down
the obama library so congrats obama on
helping usher this stuff in well i've
also been saying that they will come for
thomas jefferson and the reason i bring
up thomas jefferson a lot is because he
is my favorite of the founders uh i've
been to monticello his home in virginia
many times they they run an
extraordinary tour there where actually
they spend most of the time talking
about slavery it's actually i would say
quite disproportionate relative to the
breadth of his entire career and work
and life all of the incredible
scientific things that he did and the
incredible political documents that he
wrote and all that he had a checkered
past there's no doubt that he owned
slaves there's a lot of evidence that he
had relations with more than one slave
and potentially had a child with at
least one slave these are all true
statements and we are all just men of
our times and if you think that the
people that are canceling everybody now
are better than those people back then
who were freeing people albeit uh you
know say inconsistently um
yeah you're just mistaken because our
politicians are far far worse than any
of these people well anyway new york
city's coming from thomas jefferson i've
got a quote from the new york times we
don't source the new york times that
often but i thought we'll do it today
for more than a hundred years a seven
foot tall statue of thomas jefferson has
towered over members of the new york
city council in their chamber at city
hall a testament to his role as one of
the nation's founding fathers and the
primary author of the declaration of
independence the primary author of the
declaration of independence i
editorialize there but for the last two
decades some black and latino council
members citing jefferson's history as a
slaveholder called for the statue to be
banished a push that gained significant
momentum in the last year as the nation
has broadly reconsidered public
monuments that can be viewed as symbols
of systemic racism on monday city
officials voted to unanimously remove
the statue from council chambers but
delayed a decision on where to put it
jefferson embodies some of the most
shameful parts of our country's history
adrian adams a councilwoman from queens
and co-chair of the caucus said at the
hearing
now i just want to reiterate
dave try not to curse
these people are stupid idiots okay
that's what they are they are
self-righteous navel gazing ridiculous
buffoons thomas jefferson
basically
authored the declaration of independence
not by himself right there's many
documents going back and forth in
letters where he was working with the
other founders on it but the document
that freed us as a nation
from england he authored it he was
writing the very documents that were
freeing the slaves as he was a slave
holder and the bigger issue is first off
none of us
none of us are not are completely
innocent none of us do you think that
this woman what was her name adrian what
do you think that adrian over there is
completely innocent my guess is adrian
is probably a racist
she's probably a modern racist adrian
adams the councilwoman from queens that
the idea that jefferson embodies
systemic racism it's so evil and not
only is it evil they're never going to
stop this is the point that everyone
must understand at this point they are
never going to stop we must stop trying
to rationalize with them use logic
insane arguments with them they're never
going to stop they will be burning down
your house and you will go oh my god
well they do make a good point about
gender pronouns we better you know oh my
god they're here is that a him or her
with the torch outside of the house that
has the sign i'm coming inside to kill
you in a few minutes is that oh it's a z
okay
you see we got a problem here we got a
real problem here and then it hit me
i'm not the only one who's been warning
that they might come for thomas
jefferson there's this orange man
michael did you figure out his name
trump yes oh donald trump yes yes yes
we're not allowed to talk about him
anymore but there was this orange man he
was president for four years you know
they memory hold the [ __ ] out of that
thing but he was president of four years
and i remembered that at one time uh he
brought up that they're gonna come for
thomas jefferson we've got video tape
george washington was a slave owner was
george washington a slave owner
so will george washington now lose his
status are we going to take down excuse
me are we going to take down are we
going to take down statues to george
white
how about thomas jefferson what do you
think of thomas jefferson you like him
okay good are we going to take down the
statue because he was a major slave
owner now we're going to take down his
statue
so you know what it's fine you're
changing history you're changing color
yeah
yeah orange man
credit where credit's due
you got it right that's right not only
are they going to come for thomas
jefferson but they will come for george
washington the first president of the
united states
who stepped down voluntarily after the
civil war even though people wanted him
to remain president and in charge of the
army and he did not want that kind of
power he thought it would be dangerous
imagine one of our ridiculous
politicians giving up power
voluntarily these people were so much
better than us it's ridiculous
myself included they were so much better
and braver
and more thoughtful and more serious
about life
and built something so extraordinary
that we're literally just handing away
right now that's what we're doing and
trump makes a great point on the george
washington front because they're going
to come for him and i've also been to
mount vernon which i'm sure many of you
been to that was george washington's
estate right outside of washington dc uh
which you can go visit and his remains
are there and one of the things that
they talk about they also do a
tremendous amount about slavery you take
the tour and it's mostly
close to mostly about slavery so it's
not that they're ignoring the history
but they will come and they will burn
down
mount vernon and they will do it with a
smile on their face because they will be
stopping
racists
what are you gonna do